all right Wizards of the Coast you uh
failed that intimidation rule do you
want to try and roll persuasion you're
going to be doing it a disadvantage
[Music]
why is the Dungeons and Dragons
community so angry some of you already
know what's going on some of you may
have just caught the whiff of what's
going on and are maybe curious some of
you might haven't the slightest clue
what it is I'm even referring to don't
worry I'll go over the basics I do want
to emphasize what I'm going to go over
is just the basics because I kind of
want to talk about how this is revealing
of larger corporate mentalities and that
it's not the first time it's happened
and while disappointing it's not
surprising like at all so we are going
to be talking about Dungeons and Dragons
uh and Wizards of the Coast which is the
company that controls it which itself is
a subsidiary of Hasbro so um Dungeons
and Dragons used to be its own thing was
the coast spotted a while back and now
Hasbro has bought them
so yeah as I said this is not going to
be super detailed in terms of the
granular level of exactly every specific
detail that has changed I'm going to be
talking in Broad Strokes about the
overall impact and if I get something
wrong keep in mind that I feel like I
have a pretty good handle on why the
community is upset even if some of the
specific wording and terminology I might
not have 100 down if you want a complete
breakdown of exactly what has been
changed there are people like with legal
backgrounds who have gone over this
thing with a fine two fine-tooth comb
and you give you every single detail of
what is being changed in the possible
implications of that I'm not going that
granular on this I just I frankly I
don't have the spoons and as I said
other people have done that already now
instead I want to talk about the
mentality behind it because I kind of
feel like the nuts and bolts uh and the
people who are the most directly
impacted and just outraged are kind of
getting the most oxygen right now and I
just kind of want to talk about how
yeah this is uh
this is corporations I don't know what
you were expecting but what was it that
even happened okay so Dungeons and
Dragons which you've probably heard of
especially if you're on a geeky Channel
but it is a tabletop role-playing game
kind of the definitive one not the first
and not even necessarily the best but
certainly the most prolific most
well-known and probably the most popular
by any kind of sales metric it is a game
that that allows uh one person generally
referred to as the dungeon master to
craft a story in which other players uh
get to create uh their own individual
characters work their way through the
story it can be done as a completely uh
already created story that you can buy
sort of these uh modules for you can
make up your own just using the base set
of rules that d d has in place for
things like magic and different races
and what these things can do you can mix
in your own degree of Homebrew material
in terms of coming up with your own
races or classes or your own monsters
you can mix and match to whatever degree
you want to just have a real good time
creating a story with friends that's
ultimately what it is
now for about the last 20 years it's
been operating under what's known as the
ogl the open game license and the way
the open game license works is basically
why you have stuff like Dimension 20 and
critical role which the specifics of the
narrative are very much especially as
time has gone on been their own thing
but it's built on top of a core basis of
things like Dungeons and Dragons so they
take that framework which you know you
do buy you buy the resource books or if
you choose to subscribe to d d Beyond
which is a website with a lot of the
resources on it you can do that in some
way you have gotten a hold of these
rules and then built your own stuff on
top of that and some people have been
able to create very lucrative franchises
that they are allowed to monetize and
are their own creative expression that
they have ownership of and that's
because of the way the ogl works or
rather worked which basically meant that
that whatever you make using these rules
that's yours that's the really boiled
down version of the ogl
well the ogl is being changed what
happened I guess was a week two weeks I
don't know this this actually feels like
it's been going on
um a lot longer than it has but a
revision to the ogl got leaked now
the new ogl ogl 1.1 which is not yet in
effect and is probably being re-revised
um because of the Fallout I'll get to
the Fallout but the short version is is
that it is saying if you create
something using our works and it makes
over a certain amount of money we expect
residuals on that
while you can create whatever you want
if it's created through our system we
take ownership of it
and it basically is locking down the
freedom
of the ogl
and Dungeons and Dragons players are
pissed about this
and not unreasonably because you know
understand the use of the ogl was
everything from just creating your own
like little
um module that you could then make
available to people like hey I created
this thing for DND and like you didn't
have to officially go through
um Wizards of the Coast and get and get
it licensed on a contract like you made
a thing that is compatible with DND
using DND user rules here here let's let
here if you want this you can have it
here's a Nifty new uh story with a
creature that I had you just make that
available you didn't have to worry about
licensing cease and desists the ogl
meant that that stuff didn't happen
and now it can and again the the exact
wording is not something I'm going to
get into but it is absolutely a reversal
of the spirit of the ogl and Wizards of
the Coast has been since it has landed
as I said
extremely badly with the DND Community
Wizards of the Coast has been trying to
walk it back to being like oh well I
guess we rolled on that one on that yeah
what a contrived line that was and right
now nobody's buying it but they are
saying that they are rolling stuff back
one of the major things that they are
saying they are not going to include
when they actually do move forward is
one of the things that was in there was
that it was going to be retroactive
meaning you remember how I said they
would claim uh ownership over anything
that doesn't have a licensing agreement
that was made with their system the
original version of the update was going
to be retroactive meaning anything
created under
um Dungeons and Dragons 5e which is the
current system was going to be something
they would lay claim to if they so chose
even if it was created prior to the
update on the ogl which is which was
admittedly a very large part of the
sense of betrayal because suddenly What
Faith Can you have in anything you
create that it can be yours even if a
contract says oh it no it's totally
yours but if that contract gets revised
in a way that says it's not anymore even
if you made it back when we said it was
tough
and again this is very revealing of
corporate mentalities as I said that
looks like the part they're probably
going to roll back on but everything
about this in general regardless of the
specifics to DND
this is very
um well established
corporate mentalities
especially when it comes to interactive
medium and gaming because while Dungeons
and Dragons is in many ways different
from say video games which are going
through a lot of nonsense right now in
terms of monetization and being built
around that and maximizing that and not
really caring if anybody enjoys the damn
game or not Dungeons and Dragons hasn't
really been the subject to that kind of
monetization the way Dungeons and
Dragons makes money is just through
various Deals they cut with licensees
because like there's an official Lord of
the Rings mod for Dungeons and Dragons
and things like that there's all this
ancillary stuff die sets new rule books
settings
um the subscriptions on DND Beyond
there's all these kinds of ways but
what was noted by Executives at Hasbro
was that the audience was quote
under monetized
and that yeah that's corporate thinking
and it's not at all shocking that it
happened after Wizards of the Coast was
bought by Hasbro
because Wizards of the Coast while not a
small company was small enough
that they seemed to understand how
important the Goodwill of their customer
base was
because whatever else went on and
there's certainly some d d players who
like get uppity about every little
change people argue over what's the best
rule said Etc like there's all that kind
of stuff but it's a very engaged fan
base
and that Goodwill
that is priceless
unless you're Hasbro which is a much
bigger company basically corporate
mentality tends to scale up you can get
corporate mentality at any at any
Corporation at any scale I actually had
a recent conversation with a friend
about a significantly smaller uh company
that I'm absolutely not going to name
um but you know they were telling me
some stuff about what was going on when
as they were interacting with this
company and at first I was like boy I
wasn't really expecting that but then I
realized the only reason I wasn't
expecting is because they were smaller
than I would have expected but I'm like
the mentality is there it's a question
of scale because when it was just
Wizards of the Coast they seemed to
understand
the old mentality of uh you can fleece a
sheep as many times as you want you can
only skin it once
but you go to larger scale copper
mentality and they say why haven't you
skinned that sheep
so this is also very much in line with
stuff that we have seen in the video
game industry so I didn't make that
comparison idly because this is taking
cue from a number of actually generally
recognized as very big blunders from the
video game industry
but the fact that they went over badly
there before doesn't make it any more
surprising or any less surprising rather
that it happened here here's some
examples of how this has gone on before
because the general mentality of this is
basically a corporation going hey you
know that thing that our fans and our
customers do that gets them really
engaged with and it just shows a love of
our product
monetize it that's ours claim it
so other examples of that back when
Nintendo uh did this whole program where
if you tried to live stream or do Let's
Plays of their games without signing up
for a program by which they would get a
cut of any Revenue they would do take
down strikes on what you were doing
so they tried to do that uh for a while
eventually abandoned that but yeah for a
while
they went hey you know those things
where people just love our games so much
and people want to see them play it yeah
grind money out of that demand a cut
and then there was one of the many
Activision Blizzard uh bungles but that
particular one that I'm thinking of in
this case was with an update to an older
game that being Warcraft 3 when there
was Warcraft 3 reforged it was uh
supposedly an update
one of the things that it absolutely did
update was updated and user agreement so
that anyone who created anything using
the tools built into the game that
allowed you to make custom levels or do
your own kind of thing and then create
it for people if you did it using their
tools they now owned it
and the reason for that was very clear
because the entire genre that is known
as mobas uh was basically created by a
Warcraft 3 mod they wish they could have
claimed ownership of that and they
couldn't so they thought well we won't
let that happen again
here's the thing though
there's a difference between well this
is the way it's always been and feeling
like something's been taken from you
and that mentality also come back to in
a minute but like the general idea if if
when Dungeons and Dragons you know last
time they did an update to the end user
agreement if it didn't have the ogl
we wouldn't now be demanding one most of
us would just assume I mean that that's
just not something we're ever going to
have
but we've had it
we've had it for a while now
and taking it away you can call it ogl
1.1 but taking the old one away
you know you're removing something that
people love
about your game you're removing it or
paywalling it or gatekeeping it
and people will always feel the sting
more about something that they had and
you take away from them than about
something that you just never gave them
in the first place
that having been said though
there is another good comparison to make
to video games and it kind of comes to
what I mentioned before uh even though
this kind of tactic has gone down very
badly with other examples it's not
surprising that Hasbro did it
because this again is a pretty standard
tactic
a company does a thing that would make
them a lot more money but the customers
don't go for it
well
wait a few years somebody will try again
maybe the same company maybe maybe not
but all the companies that do the same
thing will recognize boy that would make
us a lot more money so the wait a few
years and they'll try again
and then if that doesn't work they'll
wait a few years and they'll try again
and again to use the video game
comparison so much stuff that is now
microtransactions used to be standard
alternate costumes uh different lines of
dialogue for characters these things
used to be built into the games at most
like unlocked through gameplay or maybe
a cheat code if you want to go way back
now you have to pay for them
but we've now been in a world where
paying for them has been standard long
enough that there are entire generations
of Gamers that for them that's just how
it's always been you have to be my age
to go no but we lost something they took
it from us
they kept hammering at the idea until
it's stuck
and
Hasbro and wizard of the coast has
tipped their hand to that even if
the revision to the ogl is not nearly as
restricted heck even if they scrap the
revision 100 and just leave it as is
they've tipped their hand for what they
want to do
and that's not surprising at all
because while a organization that has a
better understanding of its actual
customer base would value the loyalty
and the enthusiasm of those customers
the further away you get from that so
especially in the case of a company
acquired by a larger company that larger
company is just looking at the numbers
it's just looking at your customers it's
just looking at how you've monetized it
and they're going
you really could be squeezing more money
out of them you're leaving money on the
table
fix that we could be squeezing them for
more money we could be less generous we
could be more demanding and more
controlling and it would get us more
money
foreign it'll be curious to see if the
size of the Dungeons and Dragons players
Revolt is as big as it looks right now
because
there seems to be a pretty good head of
steam behind people abandoning DND
canceling their uh their DND Beyond
subscriptions to the point that so many
people rush to cancel their
subscriptions that actually crash the
account management page on the site but
overall this has a lot of momentum and I
think the thing that DND has failed to
realize is people can go other places
the ogl
is probably one of if not the primary
reason why d d is the dominant gaming
system but if that's not there anymore
why stay there are plenty of other
systems there are other systems that if
you talk to people who use a lot of
systems and go oh this is better than
DND there's plenty of arguments to be
had about whether systems are better and
there's lots of other systems that
plenty of people I know go oh yeah
that's better than d d but they still
use DND because of the community
and a lot of that communities built
around the ogl
so the thing that made you bigger
you're gonna destroy by attempting to
milk more money out of it
it is looking at something going we
could be making more money
right now
and saying do it
and they don't really care about the
long term Wizards of the Coast did when
they were in an independent company
because they had to worry about you know
staying a solvent business
Hasbro doesn't have to worry about that
Hasbro
can go well look just try it try and
milk everything we can out of it worst
case scenario it tanks the company we
close it down and we get to have a big
write-off and we still make the
investors happy because we'll have be
seen as cutting cost
from Hasbro's perspective
they don't care if an individual branch
of the company has long-term viability
they care about what it's doing right
now because they can always just shut it
down
Wizards of the Coast when it was an
independent company wasn't going to do
that because they weren't in a position
and they go well
we could make more money it might burn
the entire fan base but let's roll the
dice because they would have been
gambling the entire company on that
Hasbro's just gambling an asset
they're not gambling their future
as a conglomerate
and this is what happens
when corporations get this big this is
what's going on with Warner Brothers
right now as
any reason to have HBO Max is being
steadily Stripped Away because it saves
on costs
even as it makes the proposition of
having HBO Max less and less appealing
because there's less and less stuff on
it
they don't care
they don't care about anything but the
numbers
and that is almost always what happens
now I hate the fact I hate the fact that
I'm about to praise Disney but Disney's
one of the few and I'm not okay with how
big Disney is and I don't like how many
companies they've acquired but when it
comes to actually letting them continue
to manage themselves in the way that
they were before Disney's probably one
of the best because by and large they
buy a company that's doing well and say
keep doing what you're doing you'll have
more money to do more of it
and maybe there's you know a certain
amount of demand to crank out more stuff
than is necessary looking at the MCU
right now but they're not going in
fundamentally saying uproot your entire
plan they just want you to scale up
whereas when a t bought Warner Brothers
they immediately started messing with a
ton of stuff and then when Warner
Brothers merged with Discovery they're
just throwing a bunch of stuff away and
when Hasbro acquires Wizards of the
Coast they see a chance to make more
money they don't care if it runs the
company into the ground
and let's not even get started on the
list of video game studios that were
acquired by Electronic Arts to be shut
down a few years later after Electronics
Arts mandated certain changes to what
they were doing and ran the company into
the ground corporations being this big
is bad for everyone
except those big corporations and
understand that when I say that if you
are a smaller company you get bought by
those big corporations you are not
suddenly included as part of the big
Corporation for whom this benefits you
are at a separate level the executive
class of the parent company
are the ones who benefit them and the
shareholders
nobody else
no company that is acquired
is in a better position why do they let
themselves get bought for the money
whoever the owners are getting paid out
huge amounts of money sometimes there's
threat of a hostile takeover sometimes
there's threats from the larger
companies that hey if you don't let us
buy you we will find a way to choke off
your entire business and kill you
because that happens the amount of power
that corporations and conglomerates have
yeah of course this happened
and again they're walking it back
we'll see how far they walk it back
but it's also tipped their hand
something like this will be tried again
they'll go oh okay so we went a little
too far
we tried to you know make this leap
what if we only take it to here well
they'd let us get away with that because
once we're here we get them used to this
then we could go here and here and here
and here and here oh look we ended up at
the place where we tried to jump to
immediately took us longer but we got
there
again you can look at
video games
for a lot of stuff like that you would
see the egregious
things done with stuff like loot boxes
that was an overstep
but you know what the thing is
before loot boxes there still used to be
a bigger outcry over
microtransactions in general
about overpriced dlc about stuff being
sectioned off that used to be part of a
standard game experience but once loot
boxes happened that was so much worse
everybody got mad about that and once
loot boxes started being less readily
apparent in as many games
well
people weren't complaining about the old
thing that used to be a problem anymore
if you keep pushing the envelope
while you might piss some people off
there's also a chance that maybe now
they'll be relieved when you go back to
the earlier thing that really shouldn't
have been okay
Wizards of the Coast went too far and
too hard
but they've revealed where they want to
be they've revealed the level of power
and the position that they want to be in
compared to the users
and like there's a whole other thing
it's questionable how legally defensible
the new ogl even is because like there's
this whole thing where you can copyright
all of the elements of the game like the
specific words of things specific
designs images you know in the case of
Monopoly like the board design all
that's copyrighted you can't actually
copyright the rules of a game
so
in theory
if people still wanted to keep using DND
they can still use the root not using
their Source books you're going to have
to basically
kind of rework the rules into your own
wording so you're not violating the
copyright maybe change the names of some
of the races or whatnot but you can
through your own worded means have the
same effective rule set
legally
but you know that also kind of gets into
the same issue as how
um fair use is supposed to work on
YouTube which is that
yeah that might not hold up in court
but that just means that if they ever do
implement this as it was originally
worded Hasbro will just make sure he
never goes to court
they'll cut licensing deals with the big
names with critical role with Dimension
20 with whoever
and the smaller people will just will
just have to either and just kowtow to
it or abandon it all together because
while they might be legally in the right
they won't have the means to fight it to
make the comparison with YouTube the way
fair use is supposed to work to use
elements of something in order for the
purposes of of criticism critique
analysis or parody
that gets abused a lot with copyright
claims on this platform
and the thing is
most of the cases at least from my
experience definitely most of the cases
where I've had videos claimed even
though it was clearly fair use
I had to stop fighting it
because eventually it got to a point
where
the only way for me to fight this
is to actually take them to court
and I cannot afford to do that
and so I'm at the whims
of corporate overlords who are
technically
extending their influence beyond the
boundaries of what the law is supposed
to allow
but you need to have the funds and the
resources to actually get Justice and
most of us don't
we'll see what happens as I said this
was much more about
um an analysis of corporate greed and
just putting this into the context of
yeah yeah of course this happened this
happens all the time and it's going to
keep happening it's going to keep
getting worse
companies are too big
but our government won't make them
smaller
what are your thoughts on any of this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it
patreon's how I pay the bills any amount
you can support me with is of great
assistance even if you can't like share
subscribe helps me out but what I really
want you to remember is that you are
beautiful you're valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
foreign
supporter Shout Out Time folks so thank
you to Robin Moore Zubin look fulla to
rock the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Kangas bjornison Linda
Walters IMU delki Theo the Boyd toy
lowly Becky spark so Nabi lacks the
poodle Zack Tracy Scrabble General
contact unit Problem Child angry Casper
Tim price Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay
and Brendan Larose thanks so much for
your help you can get your name right
out too check out the rewards in the
patreon
what they should do should they check
the paper
[Music]